the West End in central London a
constant flow of buses and taxis ferry
shoppers to the Capitals retail
heartland but this part of town has a
dirty secret the author of T is the
busiest shopping street in Europe in a
cruel twist it also has the highest
nitrogen dioxide levels in London
nitrogen dioxide or no.2 is copped up by
diesel engines the UK sets a limit of 40
micrograms of no.2 per meter cubed of
air a minute ago there when bus was
idling by us we had a reading of 73,000
particles per cubic centimeter of air
just quite high last year this
monitoring station recorded an average
of three times the limit these levels
are the highest in Europe and greater
than even Beijing the UK government
estimated there were 29,000 premature
deaths in 2010 as a result of no.2
poisoning so why is London the main
offender it's the law of unintended
consequences
EU efforts to fight climate change
favoured diesel over gasoline because it
emits less of another pollutant carbon
dioxide in London the majority of the
bus and taxi fleets run on diesel but
just two minutes walk from the hustle
and bustle of Oxford Street it's not all
doom and gloom getting levels here of
about five or six thousand particles per
cubic centimeter
we will get n levels of around 70
thousand seventy three thousand on
Oxford Street for those of us without
air quality monitors Andrews develops an
app designed to show areas of
contamination and you can see in
Grosvenor Square here their levels of
pollutant are much much lower if you're
commuting if you're traveling each day
one of the ways that you can really
reduce your exposure to pollution is by
taking back streets trying to come
through parts and that's one of the
things that the app tries to do while
the UK struggles to bring no.2 under
control apps like this could be the best
way to dodge the smog Thom Gibson
Bloomberg